The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: There's so many
things that we're going to
start with today, one,
is we're going
to review the quiz.
And we'll be real
quick on that.
Then, we're going to talk
about object oriented
programming, which is something
that you'll probably
be more interested in for
your problem set.
So just going down problem (1):
it's false, true, false,
false, false.
Does anyone have any
questions on this?
No.
Everyone good with that?
Anyone wonder why if
something's true?
Or why something's false?
AUDIENCE: Why is the
second one false?
PROFESSOR: Why is it false?
AUDIENCE: Why?
PROFESSOR: It's true.
Because, and this is an English
thing, so, or language
thing, so it can kind
of trip people up.
But it's basically saying that
there are some problems that
you need to use recursion
or iteration to solve.
AUDIENCE: Why do you always
have to use [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, if you have a
large number of inputs or the
inputs are variable, the point
is that there are certain
problems that you would need to
use recursion or iteration
to solve them.
There are some that you don't.
But this is just asking if there
are problems that exist.
AUDIENCE: Can you
use brute force?
PROFESSOR: Well, brute force
usually involves
some sort of iteration.
Because you have to iterate
through all
the possible solutions.
Any other questions?
OK.
So the next one, this is just
an exercise in code reading.
And we can actually just
look at how it runs.
If I run like that.
Also, if you don't have your
quiz, I have them up here, if
you want to pick it up.
But that's just the output
of that code.
Does anyone not see
how that works?
Or want me to step through it?
Question (3) was the double
recurring question.
And those are the two answers
we're were looking for.
Does anyone not see
how that works?
Or want to try and
walk through it?
The way to tackle this problem
is walk through in your head.
Let's take the first
set of input.
At the top, that's your
initial call.
Now, the string, s, here, is
not less than 1, right.
You're going to go to this
double recursive call here.
So that means you're going
to get as you return.
And the way I got this at
is, I'm just taking s
from one to the end.
What this means is
that this part is
going to execute first.
And it's the same thing.
Go into the function.
This is now s.
This is obviously not only
one character long.
So we're going to have, again,
another double recursive call.
And it's going to
look like this.
Now, I've got this call
to contend with.
This string is one
character long.
So what does it do?
It just returns the input.
So, this function call is
just going to return t.
And, then, this function
is going to get
called with t, again.
And we already know what happens
when you can pass a t.
That means that this whole
function here, results in t.
Then, we tack on the a.
That means this function call,
'at', returns 'ta'.
And then we pass it into this
outer function here.
And we can already guess what
this is going to return
because for this input it just
reversed the characters.
It just flipped them.
For 'ta', it's going
to flip them again.
The entire function call
here, results in 'at'.
And then we just append
'm' to it.
The entire return for
this one is 'atm'.
It's tricky, but you've just got
to step through the code
and step through the functions
and look at each step, what
the function is getting
as input.
This was the coding question.
Most of the questions up until
now has been, can you read
code and understand
what it's doing.
This one asked you to actually
implement a function.
When you start with these
questions you should always
start from the specification.
So, this function is assuming
that we have a list of words
in lowercase.
lStr is a string of
lowercase letters.
All the letters in
lStr are unique.
And that the return of the
function are going to be all
the words in word list that
have a one to one mapping
between the letters in
the word and lStr.
In English, let's say that
my lStr is raft.
Ok.
Assuming that I have a fairly
complete word list, I'm going
to have two words that are going
to meet that criteria.
I can say there's
an r, a, f, t.
That's pretty obvious.
And then we have a t, f, a, r.
That's what we're looking at.
A lot of you did something where
you iterated through all
the words and then you had
another loop inside that tried
to find this correspondence.
The way that we solved it--
and there are multiple
solutions to this.
So if your solution worked,
you got full credit.
But the solution that we came up
with is first, we're going
to take the letters in lStr and
we're going to sort them.
So we're going to
have a, f, r, t.
Alphabetically.
And then for each word in word
list, we're going to do the
same thing.
Raft becomes a, f, r, t.
Fart becomes a, f,
r, t, as well.
Then it becomes just a simple
string comparison.
And all you have to do is
iterate through the word list.
Does that make sense
to everyone?
Our solution has a trick.
You don't need to
use this trick.
A lot of people didn't and
they got full credit.
But this is one way
of doing it.
Question (5).
This was the one where we asked
you to find the problem
with this code.
Or, rather we asked does this
code meet the specification.
When you get a question like
that, first thing you should
do is actually look at
the specification.
Then, you should look for what
this code needs to do.
Because the specification is
going to tell you what the
function needs to do.
If it doesn't say you need to do
something then, that means
it's undefined.
Right?
So In those cases, you can do
whatever, as long as you meet
the specification.
The first requirement is it
returns a list of the
pointwise sum of the elements.
That's the first requirement
of the specification.
And then it gives you 2
implicit requirements.
One is this example, where it
says if I'm given two vectors,
this is what I expect
the return to be.
In this case, the vectors are
two different lengths.
It's also saying that your
vectors are not always going
to be the same length.
In that case, you take the
pointwise sum up to the
shorter of the two lists and
just tack on the remainder
from a longer list.
So that's the second
requirement.
The third requirement is, if
you have two empty lists
you're going to return
an empty list.
And, finally, your fourth
requirement is, does not
modify input.
Now, you know the four
requirements from the
specification.
And. now, you need to look in
the code and see if this code
matches all those
requirements.
The first one.
Does it return a list containing
the pointwise some
of the elements.
Well, this is the portion of
the code that does that.
It looks like it meets
that specification.
Result is going to be the longer
of the two vectors.
In this case if v1
longer than v2.
We set result to v1
and other to v2.
That's the shorter.
Then, if we choose the longer,
we set result to v2.
And other to the shorter
of the two vectors.
Does everyone see that?
We iterate through and we
get the pointwise sum.
We meet the first requirement.
The second requirement is that
if we're given two vectors
that are different lengths then,
we're going to sum up
the furthest that we can, up to
the length of the shortest
one an tack on the remainder.
Well, again, this for loop here,
that does a pointwise
sum, it only goes up to the
length of the shorter list.
Second requirement met.
Third requirement.
Two empty vectors returns
an empty vector.
Well, if I have an empty
vector here, this
is going to be 0.
This FOR loop is never
going to execute.
And my result is going
to be empty.
And, then, finally that leaves a
fourth requirement, does not
modify the input.
What's result?
Result is what we're ultimately
returning.
And that's the only thing
that we really
modify in this function.
Result in this case,
is v1 or v2.
But they're aliased.
So it's modifying the inputs
and that's a violation.
So the answer to this problem is
a total of six characters.
Some of you wrote entire
redefinitions of the function
or, copied Ryan's code
from the reviews.
Perfectly acceptable, but
way too much work.
Remember, programmers
are lazy.
That's all we were
looking for.
If you used the code from Ryan
or, you had a different
implementation that met the
specifications, but was
completely different you
got full credit.
You have a question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
.
I'm just trying to figure out
what the distinction is
[INAUDIBLE]
do a dot copy.
Why one is better
than the other.
PROFESSOR: Dot copy applies
only to dictionaries.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
PROFESSOR: So if we try and
do a dot copy on a list.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Got it.
I think we took one point
for that or something.
We knew what your intent was but
you didn't have your IDE
there with you.
Question (6) was another
exercise in code reading.
The way that I would attack this
one is to figure out what
the two functions do first.
Let's take the easier
of the two, addUp.
Takes a dictionaries input and
it has a variable result that
it initially sets to 0.
And then it iterates through all
the keys in the dictionary
and adds them to result.
Basically, its assuming that the
values in the dictionary
are some sort of number, and
it's summing them up, and
returning the total.
And, then, this f
function here --
takes the dictionary it
zeroes out any of the
keys it might have.
And then it iterates through
all the characters in s.
If the character is already in
the dictionary then, it's
going to add 1 to it.
So it's going to increment it.
And if the character isn't in
the dictionary, then, it's
going to set up to 0.
Then, it's going to return
the result in dictionary.
Knowing that, the function
becomes pretty easy.
f of abbc for d1, which is
an empty dictionary.
Just walking through it,
starting from this point, if
we iterate a, it's not going
to be in the dictionary.
So we're going to
set d of a to 0.
Then, we move on to the
next character, b.
b is not in the dictionary.
So d of b becomes 0.
Now, we get one of
the second b.
b Is now in the dictionary.
So we increment b.
Now, d of b is 1.
Then, we move on to the final
character, c, again not the
dictionary.
So we set d of c to 0.
Then, we return the
dictionary.
That means that in my
dictionary, I have three keys
a, b, and c.
And they have values 0,
1, and 0 Respectively.
So add up is going
to return 1.
And same process for
all of these.
Question I have here is what
happens when Python
gets to that line?
Anyone.
It's going to be an error.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Result is
a local variable.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Result is a local variable
to addUP.
There you go.
So, again, the approach to this
problem is to figure out
which each of the functions
do, and then right walk
through the code.
Did anyone have trouble with
this or want me to actually
step through it?
First, when f gets an integer,
it just prints out
the integer in binary.
And then, this loop here,
prints out the binary
representations from 0, 1, 2.
Why is the first output
none in this case?
Because in that first
iteration i is 0.
When f is called, n,
is going to be 0.
It's just going to
return nothing.
So it gives you nothing.
Now, the next question was under
the assumption that the
log base 2 is o of n, what is
the order of the function, f?
And to figure this out, you know
that this function here
is o of n, because
we told you.
We know that that's one
of the first things
that's called in f.
So automatically, a run
time is o of n.
Now, this loop here, iterates
how many times?
Log n.
Well, log base 2n,
to be explicit.
For this function, which is
the dominating term here?
When we want to see o of n, it's
just going to be that.
If you had o of n plus log n,
I think we took a point.
Just because when we talk about
worst case scenario,
we're looking for what the
dominating portion of this
function is.
How does it do it?
You want to walk through
the code now?
Alright.
First thing it does, is it gets
something it's calling
curve digit.
All that is, is you take the log
base 2 of a number you're
going to get the number of
binary digits in it.
Think of it as like if I have
three which binary is 1, 1.
If I take log base2 of this,
then my curve digit
is going to be 1.
I'm not sure, Python's
been around too long.
Well, 1.5 but if we truncate
it to an int
it's going to be 1.
That's kind of like our
position marker
in the binary number.
Now, we're going to iterate
while the current digit is
greater than or equal to 0.
We're basically going to start
here and move down the line in
this direction.
All it does is says if my n mod
2 -- so I'm checking to
see if it's odd or even --
if it's going to be 1 or 0.
In this case, it's going to be
1 to the power of the current
digit, which in this
case is 1.
I'm sorry, misspoke.
n is 3, The remainder
is going to be 1.
In this case 1 to the power
of 1 is going to be 1.
That's less than
n, which it is.
Then, my ans is going
to be ans plus 1.
I'm going to add 1 to the
string and construct it.
Then, I'm going to subtract
whatever this part is.
So 2 to the current digit,
in this case to the 1.
It's just going to subtract
this off.
Then, curve digit is going to be
decremented and moved here.
Then, in this iteration, curve
digit is going to be 0 and n
is going to be 1.
So 1 mod 2 is going to be 1.
Curve digit is 0.
So that's going to
be 1 less than 1.
It should print it out.
I was not prepared for that.
All right.
So. the final question --
number (8).
Big O notation, if we match
it up, does anyone
know what it is?
AUDIENCE: Upper bound.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
A lot of you put the expected
running time.
And the letters are messed
up on this but--
a lot of you put the expected
running time, but when we are
talking about Big
O, we're talking
about worst case scenario.
So, that's the upper bound.
There is an expected bound.
If you decide to do any more
algorithm analysis, you have
Big O, expected, and little o.
If I plot the run time of
a given function, my
Big O might be this.
The worst time, my expected,
might be like that.
And my absolute best case
When we say they go that's
what we're looking for.
Alright Newton's method.
What is that an example of?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
These don't look right.
You know what, I'm sorry.
This is a different version
of the quiz.
Newton's method, that's
an approximation.
Then the last one was recursion
on your test.
The answer we were looking
for was induction.
That's that.
Anyone have any actual
questions.
AUDIENCE: Go back
to number (4).
PROFESSOR: Number (4).
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What was the part
that you did not understand
with number (4)?
AUDIENCE: I thought it was
confusing how to join the
[INAUDIBLE] together or how to
go through them to see if you
know exactly [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, that's kind
of the trick we have here.
We know we have a list of words
so to iterate through
the words is just a FOR loop.
So that's what that for
word in wordList does.
To do the thing where you match
the letters one to one,
what we implemented here is, we
first take lStr and we sort
it, sort the characters
in lStr.
Then, what we do for wordList is
for each word, we sort the
characters in that word.
And what that does is, it allows
us to just directly
compare the two strings.
And if they're equal, then we've
met the criteria for
adding it into the wordList,
Or the return wordList.
That's the quiz.
If you don't have it, you
can come pick it up.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, I was just
going to ask really quick.
If you're getting a [INAUDIBLE]
string, you're
concatenating [INAUDIBLE]
strings, the empty string, why
can't you just set it equal
to the [INAUDIBLE] string?
Is there something about the
way that operates that you
couldn't do it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so if I say my
string is 'abcdef,' and I
just say sorted(s), this
returns a list.
What I'm doing with join
is I'm just converting
it back to a string.
Got it?
OK, so on to object oriented
programming.
So what can someone tell
me about classes?
What do they allow you to do?
AUDIENCE: Allow you to
define a custom type.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So one thing they allow you to
do is to define a custom type.
Now, when you define a class,
you can group your methods and
data together with something
called encapsulation.
So first stuff, we've actually
already been using classes.
We just didn't tell
you, right?
So ints, floats, dicts,
et cetera, these are
all types of classes.
And each of these, we've
already seen them, have
something called methods
associated with them, right?
Methods are basically functions
that are associated
with a given class.
So for example, if I have the
str class, which everyone's
seen, then it has, say,
a method, dot lower.
So if I have s equal--
well, let me write it
up here on the code.
If I say something like s equal
'abcdef,' I can call the
method, lower.
So we've actually already been
doing object oriented
programming.
You just didn't know it.
Along with that, classes
have methods.
And they also have
something else.
Someone help me?
What?
AUDIENCE: Parameters?
Variables?
PROFESSOR: I'm looking
for something--
terminology-wise, attributes.
So they're a way of grouping
methods and attributes.
So when we talk about
attributes, we're talking
about things that pertain to a
specific instance of a class.
So let's say that I have
a real world example.
I have a person class.
We've already kind
of seen this guy.
A person has multiple
instances.
So there's an instance
of Mitch.
There's an instance of Garthi.
There's an instance
of Phillipe.
We're all people,
mostly human.
And we all have attributes.
So we all have an age,
when we were born.
We all have a name.
Some of us have hair and other
attributes, right?
We also have actions
that we can take.
So I can talk.
And I could walk.
I can talk to you, you, you,
you, you, and you.
So a method that I could define
for a person might be
talk to someone.
So that's one way of thinking
about objects.
So object-oriented programming
also gives us something called
inheritance, right?
So I could think of--
if I'm going along with
my person analogy--
I could think of sub-classing
person if I'm willing to draw
hard binary on the genders.
You have males and you
have females, right?
And in this column, I
might have Tracy.
I'm just picking on people
who come to office hours.
And then, Garthi, et cetera.
Now, the inheritance portion
of it is important because
I've already said that one of
my methods on a person is I
can talk to people.
I can talk to other people.
It shouldn't matter if I'm
talking to Garthi, as a male,
versus Tracy, as a female.
I talk to people basically
the same.
So that gets into something
called polymorphism, which is
we treat objects with a common
super class the same as their
sub-classes.
So as another example, let's
say that I have dogs and--
what's another canine, foxes?
I'm not going to necessarily
talk to canines the way that I
talk to a person.
So they would exist with a
different super-class.
And then, we could
all be animals.
So really, what object-oriented
programming
gives you is a different way of
thinking about how you're
modeling your world.
And what I want to do is now,
instead of just talking about
these abstract things,
walk through
some concrete examples.
So the first thing that I want
to illustrate is let's say
that we want to create
a person.
But we don't want to use object
oriented programming.
Or, we don't want
to use classes.
Professor Guttag will get angry
at me if I say we're not
using object oriented
programming.
So let's say I have a function,
makePerson.
And I'm going to represent a
person as a dictionary that
has name, age, height,
weight as keys.
All makePerson does is it
takes these things as
parameters, makes a dictionary
with them as values, and then
returns a dictionary.
Then, I have a bunch of
helper functions,
like get_name of person.
All that does is
it just returns
whatever's in the name key.
I can also set the name in case
a person decides they
don't want to be
known as Mitch.
They want to be known
as Mitchell or
something like that.
So I have a bunch of these
getter and setter function.
These are called accessor and
mutator functions, whatever
terminology you want to use.
I can also define another
function that will do
something like print
out the person.
So in this case, I'm just going
to print out name, age,
height, and weight.
And to see this in action, I'm
going to make a person, Mitch,
32 70, 200.
And then, Serena, 25, 65, 130.
I don't know if these are
actually correct.
So don't quote me on it.
I have a syntax error.
So if I run this, then all it's
going to do is just print
out what I'd expect
it to print out.
I can also set my age.
So I can go back in time to
25, which is a great age.
And now, I'm 25.
Now, this is fine if you just
want to do simple things.
But the reason why we kind
of like object oriented
programming is because we
run into difficulties.
So let's say that I print
out the type of Mitch.
It says I'm a dict.
But it doesn't give me
any more information.
So that means that I could
define any random old dict and
pass it to some of my functions
that I've defined to
work on people.
And it will probably
give me an error.
It also makes other operations
kind of non-intuitive.
So let's say that I want
to figure out if
two people are equal.
Well, I could do that by
defining a function,
people_equal, or equal_people,
and passing in it a person1
and person2.
And for our intents and
purposes, it's just going to
be if they have the same name,
they're the same person.
So this is going to, of course,
do what we expect it
to do and return false, right?
Because Serena and Mitch
aren't the same person.
But it's kind of awkward.
And if we do things using
classes, it becomes a little
bit more elegant.
And you get a lot more power.
So let's say I do the exact
same thing with a class.
So I have the class keyword.
I have the name of my object,
or my class, my new type.
And then, I have this
thing called init.
All init does is it says, when
I get a new person object,
Python automatically calls init
with whatever parameters
are specified and tells the
object to make attributes or
to set itself up.
So in this case--
need a bigger screen--
I'm making a Mitch person,
all right?
And the way that you make a new
object, or an instance of
person, is you have
the class name.
And then, you pass it whatever
parameters are
specified in init.
Now, behind the scenes, Python
will create a chunk of memory.
And then, it'll call
this init function.
And it'll pass a reference
to that chunk of memory.
So visually, let's say this
is your magical memory.
Python sees us call
person, goes in,
grabs a chunk of memory--
this marker sucks--
grabs a chunk of memory and
says, this chunk of memory is
of type person.
Then, it calls init.
init says, basically, Mitch
is a reference to
this chunk of memory.
This is a self parameter.
And then, it has the
other parameters.
And then, in the init method,
all we're doing is we're
creating new attributes on
this chunk of memory.
So we're going to have
an attribute name.
We're going to have an attribute
age, height, weight.
And then, we have a bunch of
accessors or getters, mutators
or setters.
Same exact thing as the
functions that I showed, that
we had when we were trying to
do this without classes.
The difference is
that these are
lexically scoped to person.
They are methods for an instance
of type person.
Whereas before, they were just
functions that worked on
something we called a person.
But a person was actually
a dict.
So let me just run this.
So if I run this, I'm just going
to create a person, a
Mitch person and a
Sarina person.
I'm going to print out Mitch.
It's the same thing that
I had before, right?
Except I'm using a class.
Now, if I want to use one of
the accessors, so I want to
get younger again, I can just
take my object, Mitch, and I
can call the set_age method
and pass it in my new age.
And I've lost seven years.
All right, now so far, this is
just a different way of doing
the same thing, right?
But if we look at the type
of Mitch, I'm a person.
So there's now some extra
information that we didn't
have before when we were using
a dict to represent a person.
Before, it could've
been any dict.
We didn't know that it
represented a person.
The only reason that it
represented a person before we
used a class was because we
had set certain keys to
certain values.
But other than that,
it was just a dict.
Here, this is marked
as being a person.
And that also gives us some
additional kind of power,
which we'll see in
a little bit.
So now, I've done something
sneaky.
And I've created a way of
comparing Mitch and Sarina.
Before I had that function,
people_equal.
Now, I can use the double
equal operator, which is
something that we're used to.
We use it with all
the other types.
Why don't we use
it with people?
The way that we define that is
that on this person class, I
have to find this function
underbar, underbar, EQ,
underbar, underbar, right?
The underbar methods--
and underbar, underbar,
init is one of them--
have a special significance
in Python.
So in this case, the underbar,
underbar, EQ, underbar,
underbar says that if I have an
object niche, and I have a
double equal, and I have another
object, Serena, it's
going to look in the
Mitch object.
And it's going to say, does
it have an EQ method?
Does it have this method name?
In this case, it does.
So it says, OK, this object is
capable of comparing itself to
another object for equality.
And so it calls this method.
And self, in this case, is the
Mitch object, is this guy.
And the other is the
Serena object.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: So when it looks for
the EQ, does it look for EQ,
or does it look for something
that has a double equal sign,
and then go off from there?
Is the underbar, underbar,
EQ, underbar, underbar --
is it defined for all?
PROFESSOR: It's defined
for all persons.
AUDIENCE: All persons.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, I see what you're saying.
Is it defined for objects
other than
persons, like all objects?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, we can
check that out.
You notice that person
inherits from object.
This is where all classes
that you define
should inherit from.
And so object, like any other
type-- remember I showed the
dir command before?
If you do this, you can
see everything that's
inherent to an object.
So in this case, it
doesn't have the
underbar, underbar, EQ.
So it might be something special
that Python does.
So this is where I'd actually
have to look it up to answer
your question.
So I'm going to punt on that.
AUDIENCE: So it knows somehow
to look for EQ specifically?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
When it sees the double equals
sign, it knows to look for EQ.
The double underbars
signify a magical
operator or magical method.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
calling EQ, you're not
formally giving it two formal
parameters in the parentheses.
So it's presumably taking the
first name before the equals
and the second name before
the equals--
PROFESSOR: We'll
get into that.
So the question is, are we
actually explicitly passing
two formal parameters to it?
And the answer is yes and no.
This is a bit of syntactic sugar
for Python, which means
that it's a nicer way
of writing things.
But we could do something
like this.
Which is totally awkward, but
in actuality, this is what
Python does in the background.
It does this sort of mangling.
And I was actually going to
show that with something a
little bit easier
to comprehend.
So I have a method called
get_age, an accessor, right?
And usually, you call a method
by having a reference to the
object, dot, and then whatever
method name--
in this case, get_age.
You can also write it like this,
which is, if you think
about it, exactly what happened
with the double equal
operator, right?
Python took your nice,
intuitive syntax--
Mitch double equal Sarina--
and totally mangled it and made
it something that was
completely ugly.
And this is how Python would
actually see it.
So that's why, when you
write these methods,
you have a self parameter.
This self parameter
is like this guy.
Python says, ooh, I have
an object reference.
And they're calling
a method, get_age?
Do I have a get_age method?
Yes, I do.
Here it is.
OK, now I'm going to take this
and make it look ugly.
It's a person object.
So I'm going to call
person.get_age, and I'm going
to pass it Mitch, the reference
to the object.
And that becomes a
self parameter.
So that's where the self
parameter comes from.
There's a little bit of
mangling that goes on.
And it's partially
hidden from you.
In other languages, it's
completely hidden from you.
But in Python, you see
some of the ugliness.
AUDIENCE: So in this case, how
did it know I was talking
about Mitch self and not--
PROFESSOR: Serena?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So the question was
how did Python know that the
parameter was Mitch.
Because--
let me comment this out
so we explicitly
what I'm talking about.
So Mitch is a reference to a
person that represents me on a
computer, right?
Python knows that this object
is of type person because it
chunked that memory and made
it of type person.
So when it sees this reference
and it knows it's of type
person and it sees this dot
and get_age, what that
automatically tells Python is,
hey, this instance of person
is trying to call a method.
Does this class have
a method, get_age?
In this case, it does.
So python says, oh, it does.
So I'm going to call this
method, person.get_age, and
pass it Mitch as a
self parameter.
Does it make sense
in some way?
AUDIENCE: So it basically allows
you to put in the name
of the person instead of
the attribute, instead
of using the type?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
you could do this.
I don't recommend that
you do this.
I'm trying to illustrate
where the self
parameter is coming from.
It's much cleaner to write--
than it is to write this.
Fewer keystrokes, too.
Remember, programmers
are lazy.
But it'll do the same
exact thing.
So can I move on?
Wow, we've only got three
minutes left.
I don't think I'm going to be
able to get through this.
So my intent with this code was
to show inheritance with
shapes, because that's
the classic.
I'm going to define a base
class called shape.
And I'm going to give it some
methods, area, perimeter, EQ,
and less than.
For my purposes, shapes are
equal if they have the same
area, and they're less than
if the area's less than.
So when we're doing logical
comparisons,
we're comparing areas.
So now, I'm going to define
a class, rectangle.
It inherits from shape.
It's got two sides, or the
lengths of two sides.
So the area's pretty easy,
just a multiplication.
And the parameter is just the
sum of the four sides.
And then, I'm going to define
another shape, circle.
It's got a radius.
And it does the area and the
perimeter in the way that you
expect a circle to do the
area and the perimeter.
And then, I've got square,
which is a sub-class of
rectangle, because a square is
just a special case, right?
And all I'm going to do is when
I initialize my square,
I'm just going to call the
rectangle's init method, and
give it the same size twice.
So what this gives us is some
inheritance, some nice
properties.
So first off, when Python
gets to this line,
what's going to happen?
s is of type shape, right?
So what is the method
for shape?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: What is the
method for shape?
PROFESSOR: What does the area
method for shape do?
Because that's what
I'm calling here.
AUDIENCE: It's going
to throw an error.
PROFESSOR: So yeah, voila.
And the reason is that we
haven't implemented it here.
This method is a placeholder.
It's saying that if I have
a shape, it should
have an area method.
And this is something that you
should see on your problem set
when you're doing PS5
with trigger.
AUDIENCE: So it doesn't do
anything on its own.
You can ignore it and
just put [INAUDIBLE]
for a circle.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It just reminds you?
PROFESSOR: It reminds
you, yeah.
AUDIENCE: It's like
commenting.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: So it's kind
of like commenting?
PROFESSOR: It's like commenting,
except that you
get a little bit nicer
error checking.
So it is a way of explicitly
saying that if I have
something that is sub-classed
from shape, then I can be
guaranteed that there
is an area method.
But if I sub-class off it--
so rectangle, square, and
circle-- they all have
concrete implementation
for areas.
So this is all going
to run fine.
And then, I have my equality
operator and
my less than operator.
Those will run fine.
So let me--
all right.
The reason why this is useful,
and the big idea, is if I have
a list of shapes--
circle, square, and
a rectangle--
then I can treat them all
exactly the same because they
all have an area method, which
is defined on a shape.
They all sub-class from shape.
So it'll print all
those areas.
And then, if I wanted
to, I could even--
because I have a list, I can
call the sort method.
And because I've defined the
less than operator, it'll sort
the shapes in descending
order by area.
And that's what this last bit of
code does unless I comment
out my assignment.
There we go.
So I know I rushed
through the shape
implementation, and I'm sorry.
But I'm actually out of time.